hi my name is John avildsen I directed
The Karate Kid I'm sorry I can't be
there with everyone this evening I gotta
tell you this was the most fun I ever
had directing a movie it all started
with Jerry Weintraub the producer he
made everything fun
he found Robert Kaman the writer who
wrote this script that was so sweet
and the cast what a cast Pat Morita
Ralph Macchio
they were beautiful and the caterer we
had the best caterer of any film that
I've done and on Fridays sushi I still
remember I've never had such fresh sushi
it was delicious
I'm not sure mr. Appleton's memory is
what it used to be okay
the catering was horrible note to John
not all raw fish is sushi after I got
food poisoning for the third time out of
packed my own lunch and I Wednesday's
half a day we only worked half a day on
Wednesdays and every weekend Jerry gave
a pool party what party Wednesday might
have been a half a day for John but it
was a full day for the rest of us and
when you have to do your own hair makeup
and wardrobe it's kind of tough to bail
at lunchtime my Thursday afternoons
Jerry Weintraub would come to the set
with a garbage bag full of
hundred-dollar bills and just start
handing them out to everybody you know I
wished Jerry would have used some of
that money to hire a stunt man thanks to
Billy Zabka whaling on me for weeks on
end I have three fuse discs in my spine
tenuous I why are you so angry was
Karate Kid not highlight of acting
career
oh sure for nearly 30 years people have
been telling me to wax off and you got
all the good lines
first rule show business always suck up
to writer I know you're right you're
right it's a great film it's it's a it's
a big part of my life I'm very proud of
it it's just you know it's not the only
movie I've ever done I know Daniel Simon
also make two sequels